commanding lead three and a half half if
he wins the next game
it's all over and he could even
have a nap b4
before watching the football but
we're not there yet the opening is the
girl four knights
membership c5 bit of a sideline bishop
b4 as the main move
bishop c5 is playable to bishop to d3
carlson just you know playing it safe
with this lead
pawn to d6
[Music]
pawn to f4 chad is asking is this
princess elsa's room
the answer is yes
magnus carlsen is coming to us from
arendelle
it's princess elsa's room
queen h5
g6 queen h6
romeo's rook a5 threatens knight takes
d3
i guess magnus wants f5 maybe one's
knight d5
okay f5 plate weakens the e5 square
but also in a way
threatens
quite some attacks knight e5 plate isn't
there b4
uncle indigo is saying jan how often do
you commentating
not that much in english anymore because
people decided
that my voice is just too
smooth it's making everybody fall asleep
so
i was told to switch to german where
my very smooth voice gets somewhat
compensated by the beautiful
german language
so mainly i do commentary in german
these days i've done plenty in english
and magnus carson wins the exchange
this looks pretty good still his pawn
structure
is a little rotten now so it ain't over
yet
and he knows he can't just keep making
moves he goes for the
attack plays f6 hoping for
g6 queen h6
but aronia hanging in there goes rookie
6
going to c3 trying to chase this knight
away
elegant ilk is saying schweiterling
please here
what about congratulations it's a
weird combination of words to ask
butterfly and hospital
is that the butterfly effect
cars now up two exchanges but
like actually very stable
these knights have good squares even
compyboy
is not that impressed with the white
position he has
two rooks versus a knight in a bishop
and two pawns
not that clear i'd see four knight four
magnus understandably tries to simplify
but he blunders
knight takes d6 computer not a fan
i'm assuming the answer is knight tree
four
yeah live on spots it blundered by the
world champion
aronia should win this one
first real blunder we see from magnus
today the other were like
the computer would spot something that's
tough to see for humans but knight d6
934 he would usually see
and this game he's gonna lose yeah he's
upset
g3 continues the game but now it's
fairly hopeless for white
queen c5 check
queen f8 covering the back rank flex
stabilizes
just needs to make a luft h6 or h5
bring the bishop out and escape this is
too many pieces here